(Originalkommentar)
Jetzt liegt Beat Feuz in Führung.
* Pfiffe und Applaus *
(Originalkommentar) Und ein Sturz!
Halt dich fest!
(Originalkommentar)
Kriechmayr 14/100 vor Feuz.
In einer Woche geht's los.
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl, ich
bin froh, dass es endlich losgeht.
Wir haben ein Jahr lang vorbereitet,
geplant und organisiert,
jetzt sind wir froh, dass wir das
endlich umsetzen können.
OK-Präsident Urs Näpflin
hat eine Woche vor dem Rennen
auch Bagatell-Probleme zu lösen:
einer hat den Funk vergessen.
(Funk) Perfekt, danke. Und Schluss.
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo.
Alles klar?
Hatte Franz gestern zu viel Schnaps,
dass er das Funkgerät vergessen hat?
Dort ist er.
Franz, hast du gestern
zu tief in die Flasche geschaut,
dass du den Funk vergessen hast?
- Vielen Dank!
Heinzer Franz und der Oberst,
der hier die Armee führt,
haben vor 26 Jahren
zusammen einen Ehevorbereitungskurs
bei der katholischen Kirche besucht.
Franz und seine zukünftige Frau und
Daniel Amhof und seine Zukünftige
waren zusammen in diesem Kurs.
Seither haben sie sich
nie mehr gesehen.
Wir haben zwei Flaschen Schnaps,
Heiliges Wasser, organisiert
und sie den beiden an der gestrigen
Mannschaftsführersitzung gegeben.
Und jetzt hat er den Funk vergessen.
Ja, hoffentlich hat gestern nicht
zu tief in die Flasche geschaut.
Die Lauberhorn-Abfahrt
ist ein Mythos,
der Jahr für Jahr
neu inszeniert wird -
aktuell mit einem Budget
von 8 Mio. Fr.
Nur wegen des Sports
komme heutzutage kaum noch jemand,
sagt Näpflin, man müsse mehr bieten.
Das Spektakel ist wichtig,
der Sport muss spektakulär sein,
er braucht Sprünge
und schwierige Passagen.
Der Zuschauer vor Ort
oder vor dem Fernseher muss sehen,
wo der Fahrer Zeit verliert
oder gewinnen kann.
Das Spektakel darf aber nie
auf Kosten der Gesundheit der Fahrer
gehen.
Sobald es gefährlich wird, ein
Fahrer sich schwer verletzen kann
und man sieht,
dass man ein erhöhtes Risiko hat,
muss das Spektakel zurückstehen.
Die Sicherheit der Fahrer
muss immer oberste Priorität haben.
Aber das Risiko bleibt?
- Ja, deshalb tragen sie Helme.
Über 60 TV-Stationen
nutzen die Bilder aus Wengen
für eine Live-Übertragung.
Damit alles - inklusive Hundschopf -
rechtzeitig fertig wird,
stehen rund 1'800 Helfer im Einsatz.
Guido,
hier ist es gestern gut gegangen.
Schön kommen sie hier.
Auch die Schweizer Armee
schaufelt mit.
Ohne die Armee ist die Renn-
organisation für uns unvorstellbar.
Ist das alles gratis für Sie?
Wir bekommen das von der Schweiz
und der Schweizer Armee offeriert.
Weiter zum Canadian Corner
unterhalb des Hundschopfs.
Wir müssen eventuell
eine Änderung vornehmen
und einige Leute
nach Adelboden entsenden.
Wo im Moment noch
die Armee verpflegt wird,
dinieren am Rennwochenende VIPs.
Der Eintritt
kostet 900 Fr. pro Person.
Dem Vernehmen nach
wird wohl kaum gemischter Salat
mit Geschnetzeltem und Kartoffelstock
serviert.
(Mann) Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Man zahlt nicht nur fürs Essen,
sondern v.a. auch
für die exklusive Aussicht.
Ich glaube,
die Sprünge sind nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, die sind gut, ja.
- Die gehen gut.
(Funk) Nummer 5 auf der Strecke ...
Wein und Spektakel - alles inklusive.
Das OK hat gut gespürt, dass sich
alles immer weiterentwickeln muss.
Die Abfahrt muss die Basis
des Spektakels bleiben,
aber wenn man die Leute
dem Spektakel näherbringen kann,
ist das von den Emotionen her
immer besser.
Aber wenn man vorbeifährt und
hier wird Champagner getrunken ...
Daran denkt man als Fahrer nicht.
100 % nicht.
Wir denken hoffentlich erst nach
dem Rennen ans Champagnertrinken.
Wenn du auf dem Siegerpodest bist.
- Genau.
(Mann) Oh fuck!
Jetzt ist es so weit,
der erste Fahrer ist gestürzt.
Hugo Brugnoli kam vor rund 30 Jahren
von Luzern nach Wengen
und machte sich hier
einen Namen als Beizer.
Zehn Jahre lang
wirtete er im Zielschuss
und gehörte zum Lauberhorn-Rennen
wie der Hundschopf.
O je, man sieht ihn gar nicht mehr.
Brugnolis Beiz hiess Cafe Mary
und war Treffpunkt
für Trainer und Rennfahrer.
* Ländlermusik *
Da sind wir im Cafe Mary.
Hier Alberto Tomba, er kam zwischen
dem ersten und zweiten Lauf.
Er war eine gefragte Person.
Meine Mitarbeiter wollten natürlich
ein gemeinsames Foto haben.
Die haben sich
in seinen Schoss gesetzt?
Ja, das erstaunt mich auch.
Sie hatten immer gute Kontakte
zu diesen Leuten.
Was hat Tomba denn
zwischen zwei Läufen im Mary gemacht?
Er hat einen Kleinigkeit gegessen.
Meistens hat er einen Teller
Bündnerfleisch gegessen
und ein Zweierli Roten getrunken.
Pssst.
Darf ich das sagen? Ja, ja,
ich glaube, das war kein Doping.
Das Cafe Mary
ist inzwischen in anderer Hand.
Und auch sonst
hat sich vieles verändert.
Heute wäre es undenkbar, dass
ein Rennfahrer zwischen zwei Läufen
in einer Beiz mit dem Personal
schäkert und Rotwein trinkt.
So, da wären wir, das Cafe Mary.
Hallo zusammen.
* Handorgelklänge *
Hallo.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Die Zeit überdauert
hat die Geselligkeit
rund ums Laubernhorn-Rennen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
# S' Oberland, ja s' Oberland,
s'Berner Oberland isch schön.
# S'Oberland, ja s'Oberland ...
Hugo Brugnoli hat allerdings
auch traurige Erinnerungen:
z.B. an einen fatalen Sturz
im Jahr 1991.
Wie haben Sie den Sturz
damals erlebt?
Ich war in der Küche.
Damals gab es diese Tribüne
noch nicht,
das Haus war auch kleiner.
Ich sah die Fahrer jeweils
über diesen Sprung kommen.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie er gestürzt ist.
Nach der Landung hat sich sofort
eine Blutlache ausgebreitet.
Da musste man
mit etwas Schlimmem rechnen.
Der 20-jährige Österreicher
Gernot Reinstadler
startet am 18. Januar 1991
zu einer Qualifikationsabfahrt
und kommt im Ziel nie an.
(Originalkommentar) Schwerer Sturz
von Reinstadler im Zielsprung.
(Originalkommentar Hans Jucker)
Meine Damen und Herren,
liebe Sportfreunde,
wir melden uns aus Wengen.
Vielleicht haben Sie es
im Lauf des Vormittags schon gehört:
Die 61. Lauberhorn-Abfahrt
ist abgesagt worden.
Der 21-jährige Tiroler Gernot
Reinstadler aus Jerzens im Pitztal,
der gestern im Zielhang
schwer gestürzt war,
ist kurz nach Mitternacht
im Spital von Interlaken gestorben.
An Reinstadler
erinnert eine Gedenktafel in Wengen.
"Gottes Wille kennt kein Warum",
heisst es da.
Warum berührt Sie das so?
Ja ...
Ja ... Das war brutal.
Ein so junger Mensch ...
Er wollte als Sportler
Karriere machen und ...
Und dann geschieht
so ein blöder Unfall.
Ich finde das schlimm.
Schlimm ist es v.a.
für die Angehörigen,
die den Sohn verlieren.
* Friedliche Musik *
Die Tiroler Berge - hier lernte
Gernot Reinstadler das Skifahren.
Sein Elternhaus
steht in Jerzens im Pitztal.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich kann mich noch gut erinnern,
es war so wunderschön wie heute.
Um 14.30 Uhr
bin ich noch einmal hinaufgefahren.
Ich bin zusammen
mit einer Frau hinaufgefahren,
deren Sohn in der Schweiz
einen Verkehrsunfall hatte.
Ich habe mir gedacht:
"Wie schafft die das?"
Ich sagte zu mir selber:
Nachdem ich hinaufgefahren war,
ging ich nach Hause.
Ich wusste, dass in Wengen die -
was war es, eine Qualiabfahrt ...
Ja.
Ich kam zur Tür rein
und das Telefon klingelte.
Der Trainer war am Apparat.
Es sagte gleich, wir müssten
mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen.
Am Nachmittag sagte er, wir müssten
Und nachts um 1 Uhr
ist er dann gestorben.
Wir haben einen Anruf bekommen
und man sagte uns,
dass Gernot gestorben sei.
Sie haben alles getan,
aber die Verletzungen
waren einfach zu schwer.
Sie haben alles getan,
aber es war schlimm.
Und dann haben wir gewartet -
drei Tage, nicht wahr?
Ja.
Denn es braucht ja viel Zeit,
wenn es über die Grenze geht.
Wir konnten den Sarg nicht öffnen,
weil er versiegelt war,
weil er ja über die Grenze
transportiert werden musste.
Sie haben ihn gar nicht mehr gesehen?
Nein,
wir konnten ihn nicht mehr ansehen.
Und das ...
- Das ... - Ja.
Nun haben wir halt die Erinnerung,
als er gegangen ist.
Die Erinnerung daran,
wie er von zu Hause weggegangen ist.
Wie haben Sie von ihm
Abschied genommen?
Ja ... Eigentlich
haben wir nicht Abschied genommen.
Das konnten wir ja gar nicht.
Deshalb hängen ja überall
Fotos von ihm.
* Sanfte Musik *
Den Verantwortlichen in Wengen
hat sie nie einen Vorwurf gemacht.
Das Verhältnis sei immer sehr gut
gewesen, sagt Traudl Reinstadler.
Sie habe auch dieses Jahr wie immer
eine Einladung ans Lauberhorn-Rennen
bekommen und wäre auch gegangen.
Aber die Zimmer,
die sie an Feriengäste vermiete,
seien im Moment belegt,
darum brauche es sie hier.
So, jetzt gehe ich raus.
Das ist Gernot.
Ich hätte auch ein Foto von mir.
Welches?
- Ich zeige es dir.
Das war 1964
an der Olympiade in Innsbruck.
Ich war damals nur Reserve,
durfte aber im Slalom
als Vorläuferin fahren.
1964 - also vor 100 Jahren.
Jetzt kann ich dich überholen.
Jetzt überhole ich dich. Ja.
Ist das flach hier!
Sie war Skirennfahrerin
und ist auch mit 77 Jahren noch
so oft wie möglich auf der Piste.
Ich folge dir.
Heute mit ihrer Tochter
und einem ihrer Enkel.
Warum seid ihr eigentlich
eine so skiverrückte Familie?
Ja, frag mich!
Du fragst mich Sachen.
Raoul, warte!
Ich weiss es nicht.
Warum?
Ja, ich bin durchs Rennfahren ...
Aber mein Vater und meine Mutter
sind beide nicht Ski gefahren.
Aber ich halt ... Ich weiss nicht.
Sie haben halt das Ski-Gen bekommen.
Gernot hat es auch gehabt.
Und Raoul.
Und vielleicht noch Simon.
Ja, vielleicht Simon.
Mich hat es übersprungen.
Der achtjährige Raoul
erinnert seine Grossmutter
an den verstorbenen Gernot:
beide skiverrückte Draufgänger.
Ich springe aber nicht.
Nur noch zwei Tage
bis zur Lauberhorn-Abfahrt.
Der OK-Präsident ist im Dauereinsatz.
Nächster Programmpunkt:
ein Radio-Interview.
Ja, jawohl, ich höre Sie.
Ja, Frau Häberli.
Sie hören mich?
Die Tribüne, die Podeste,
die wir bauen -
alles ist reibungslos abgelaufen.
Bis jetzt hatten wir zum Glück
keine Unfälle.
Es geht alles nach Plan.
Jetzt sind wir im Rennmodus.
Jetzt ist das Wetter entscheidend.
Wir hoffen, dass wir
in den nächsten Tagen Glück haben.
Ich habe heute extra
die roten Socken angezogen.
Die bringen Glück.
Ist das so?
- Ja, klar.
Sind das seit Jahren die gleichen?
- Nein, nein.
Ich wechsle sie schon zwischendurch.
Ich meine wegen der Farbe.
- Die sind immer rot.
Rote Socken bringen Glück.
Wirkliche Gegner hat der Rennzirkus
in Wengen wohl nur wenige -
wenn überhaupt. Denn irgendwie
gewinnen alle ein bisschen.
Die Wertschöpfung ist rund 30 Mio.
für die ganze Region.
Es betrifft nicht nur Wengen,
die ganze Region
profitiert von diesem Anlass.
Unbezahlbar sind die Bilder,
die in die ganze Welt hinausgehen.
Ein Anlass ...
Ohne diesen Anlass könnte ich mir
Wengen nicht vorstellen.
Der gehört zu Wengen
und wird auch in Wengen bleiben.
Schade riecht man den Duft
nicht im Fernsehen.
Wo vor einer Woche noch Soldaten
aus Gamellen gegessen haben,
laufen nun die letzten Vorbereitungen
für die VIP-Gäste.
Am Renntag werden Häppchen gereicht,
während die Fahrer auf der Piste
Kopf und Kragen riskieren.
Für gewisse Leute
kann es den Anschein machen,
dass das sehr speziell ist.
Früher hat man immer gesagt:
"Brot und Spiele,
das will das Volk".
Das haben schon die Römer
so zelebriert.
In diesem Sinne
hat sich nicht viel verändert.
Nur die Umgebung wurde anders.
Die Gladiatoren werden am Schluss
nicht den wilden Tieren vorgeführt.
Aber die Gladiatoren
fahren hier die Piste hinunter.
Das wollen die Leute sehen.
Falls einer dieser Gladiatoren
stürzen sollte,
kommt Urs Allenspach zum Einsatz.
Der Wengener Dorfarzt
ist am Rennwochenende
jeweils Teil des Rettungs-Teams.
An und für sich denken wir alle
positiv, dass alles gut geht,
denn wir sind bereit.
Aber wir sind auch dafür bereit,
wenn es nicht gut geht,
auch dann machen wir alles, was wir
können. Wir haben alles dabei.
Wir sind bereit
von der Infrastruktur her.
Wenn es das braucht,
dann sind wir hier.
Aber wir glauben, es geht ohne uns.
Hat es Ihnen keine Mühe gemacht,
sich das Lauberhorn-Rennen
wieder anzuschauen?
Wir haben es uns immer angeschaut.
- Ja, sofort.
Am Anfang ...
Am Anfang
ist ein Franzose noch gestürzt.
Aber gleich im Jahr darauf
waren statt Netze Matten dort.
Das war natürlich schon besser.
Das war natürlich okay.
Es gab Veränderungen?
- Ja, die gab es.
Sicherheitsmässig
hat sich viel verändert.
Haben Sie sich manchmal gefragt,
warum das passiert ist?
Auf dem Grabstein steht "Warum".
"Gottes Wille kennt kein Warum",
steht da.
Und damit haben wir eigentlich ...
Warum kann man sich immer fragen.
Das kann sich jeder fragen:
"Warum ich?" "Warum wir?"
"Warum er?"
- "Warum er?"
Gottes Wille kennt kein Warum.
Wir haben
am Sonntagabend eine Messe,
eine Gedenkmesse an Gernot.
Das ist ja der 28. Jahrestag.
Das machen wir eigentlich
jedes Jahr.
Jedes Jahr wird eine Gedenkmesse
für Gernot gehalten.
Auf dem Friedhof
haben wir meistens Rosen.
Dieses Jahr
stecken wir sie in den Schnee,
weil es sehr viel Schnee
auf dem Friedhof hat.
Aber Gedenkmessen
sind bei uns einfach Brauch.
Dass man jedes Jahr
eine Jahresmesse abhält.
Ist das noch wichtig?
Ja, das ist es noch.
Aber auch für Sie, meine ich?
Ja, für alle.
Warum ist das gut für Sie?
Dass man eben doch ...
- Damit er nicht vergessen wird.
Damit er auch von den Einheimischen
nicht vergessen wird.
Der Glaube hilft Ihnen
für die Verarbeitung? - Ja.
Der Glaube hat uns sehr geholfen,
damit es weitergeht.
Und wir ihn einmal wiedersehen.
Im Himmel?
- Irgendwo.
Irgendwo.
Das glauben wir schon.
Nun ist es so weit:
der Tag der Abfahrt.
Die Häppchen auf der VIP-Terrasse
sind angerichtet.
(Speaker) Das hier feiern wir
natürlich grossartig.
Die Gladiatoren können kommen.
Herr Berset?
- ... sind sie genau gleich schnell.
Moment, es ist noch zu früh.
Der Chef des Catering sagt,
es sei so wie Brot und Spiele.
Wie früher
die Gladiatoren in der Arena.
Das ist beim Sport sowieso so.
Das ist beim Fussball nicht anders.
Das Risiko ist hier
vielleicht etwas grösser.
Sieht man die vielen Fussballverlet-
zungen an, möchte ich das verneinen.
Hier kann es tödlich sein.
Klar, aber passieren
kann überall etwas.
Die Athleten sind topfit,
die sind trainiert,
sie sind parat für so etwas.
Sie sind am besten Platz,
den es hier eigentlich gibt.
Die Fahrer riskieren ihr Leben und
Sie schauen in der Komfortzone zu.
Wie ist das?
Ich war oben, ich war unten -
das ist das Rennen.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Momente.
Es gibt auch Risiken, das ist klar.
Aber sie sind sehr gut organisiert.
Wenn man die Risiken misst,
ob jemand gewinnt oder nicht -
das ist auch Sport.
Spitzensport ist wichtig.
Nicht nur,
der Sport ist für alle sehr wichtig.
Aber diese Verbindung
ist auch hier präsent.
Hugo Brugnoli ist
dem Lauberhorn-Rennen treu geblieben.
Er geniesst es allerdings
schon seit Jahren für sich alleine.
Den Trubel habe er gesehen.
Wurde es anders?
Es wird alles anders.
Ob es besser ist oder schlechter,
kann man nicht beurteilen.
Es ändert sich einfach alles.